close the position down uh Magnus is
just a genius what can I say this is
this is why he's the world champion and
wow I was about to praise Magnus for
being Universal but Mama jarov pushing
Gary the G4 two squares you never see
this in a serious game from top players
he's just forgetting peace development
he's throwing his pawns forward he's
trying to kick away white tonight with
this Pawn
it's obviously not a good move because
you have to develop your pieces but he's
already trying to shock Magnus playing
on that psychological Factor
um this game is not going to be calm no
matter what a Magnus tries to do even if
Magnus tries to shut it down okay
stopping the advance of Black's Pawn now
manager of he's just determined he's
shown us with that move he just wants to
go down in style and uh okay now we will
see an open Sicilian but what is black
spawn doing on G5 it's so weak you could
even take it now
this is chess humor
it's just desperation from Shaq you know
he knows he's in a must-win situation